you could not live with your own failure
maybe maybe it's all yeah maybe there's
not a real frame in that whole trailer
Anthony through our entire experience at
Marvel I was always tried to make very
disruptive choices with each film at the
end of Winter Soldier good guys are the
bad guys we flip everything out it said
Civil War we divorced the Avengers and
infinity war we knew we wanted to make a
strong narrative choice there's an adage
where you write yourself into a corner
then you try to figure out how to get
out and that usually creates really
dramatic moments for the audience
there's no bigger way to write ourselves
into a corner than killing half the
characters we actually never thought of
it as a cliffhanger in our own brains we
for us we were telling a complete story
that this was Thanos's movie who's the
lead of the film and we gave him a
complete arc and he wanted a proper
ending I mean the visualization was
purely just you know we thought about
the elemental aspect of you know your
body and what happens to it and
accelerating the decomposing process in
a way right
we very thoroughly explore a lot of
different ideas before we lock into
what's exciting us most so at some point
I'm sure there were many variations but
once the story starts to take shape it
really forms in a muscular little way
around a single idea and then we spend
months working on that you know as far
as who went to dust I mean everything's
always built upon story and we'll just
say that there's a reason that the
original six Avengers are left
not not in one bed Piderman was my
favorite character growing up and it was
this notion of a child who had been
burdened with this incredible
responsibility and through very tragic
circumstances whether the death of his
uncle and you know Tony Stark and Peter
Parker developed a father-son
relationship over the course of two
films so we felt like that would that
would be hard to watch and it was it's
hard to watch on set and that was hard
to watch for the audience I think I
think it's civil wars where it started
to come into our brains because you know
as as we're executing that movie you
know we wanted to kind of break up the
Avengers and shatter that relationship
at the heart of it between Steve Rogers
and Tony Stark they're the heart and
soul of the Avengers you know so the for
the two of them to have a falling out
and have an irreconcilable problem was
really you know devastating to the team
as a whole and sort of as we were
executing it and we realized how well we
were sort of achieving that on an
emotional level with the characters
that's I when I think our brain started
to open up to oh my god they're so
vulnerable now now you're like what
happens when Thanos comes you know and
that's when our brains I think started
stepping through where the story could
go and you know in our minds that's why
the Avengers lost an infinity war you
know it's the fact that they were
divided they weren't functioning as a
team in that movie any longer and they
were so they weren't prepared for the
for the universe's greatest threat it's
complicated character I mean he's a you
know profoundly interesting villain who
is equal parts and pathetic and
loathsome
he's also frightening and intimidating
and nearly invincible and he's driven
philosophically driven and I think a lot
of people respect his monastic
dedication to his task he'll die for it
so he's an acolyte in that regard and
what's interesting about the end of that
movie is that he shuns all materialism
he's got this amazingly powerful
gauntlet that can alter the very fabric
of the universe and he retires to a
shack on some desolate planet teeming
has no intentions of doing anything
other than serving the universe our
entire process was figuring that out I
mean we knew we knew we wanted the
center the movie on the character and we
knew that we can only do that if we
pulled off the most realistic feeling
performance that you could possibly
imagine in a movie so we started very
early on with our visual effects team
specifically our visual effects
supervisor Dee and Alou and trying to
figure out how the technology can work
and we can actually achieve this we did
tests with josh brolin where he had to
come in perform and we would work on it
for several months and try to figure out
the best version of it so yeah that
character was built methodically over
the entire span of the development of
the film as storytellers we find that
one of most empathetic moments in the
story and also the other thing to focus
on his choice I mean all of these
characters make flawed choices you know
if Thor had not been so angry and so
revenge driven he may have killed Thanos
faster and he did gone for that he would
have gone for the head exactly the fact
that he wanted revenge he wanted to see
in Thanos his eyes as he was killing him
you know that's gave Thanos a window to
reverse things on him so you know it's
all these characters have emotional
vulnerabilities that complicate their
ability to do what needs to be done and
it's us sort of watching them fight
through that as part of his part of the
fun makes them interesting to watch if
all they did was make the right choice
every time I don't know you know it's a
fairly predictable and boring story
after a while I think one thing we Joe
and I love about ensemble storytelling
is you have so many different places to
go in the story at any given moment the
point of view can shift from character
to character so we wanted to commit very
fully to the idea that Thor was going to
be the hero of the movie Thor was going
off on this very individual quest to
find a way after suffering this horrible
opening seam defeat to Thanos where
Thanos kills his brother and Heimdall
and wipes out many of his people so he
is on a journey through the entire film
of revenge so the audience is on that
ride with
or the whole way and it's a difficult
road for him but he finds a way to
figure it almost kills himself doing it
yeah and so when he shows up in Wakanda
like we have gone through all the
storytelling beats to tell you Thor is
going to do this and that was you know
one of our great thrills of the movie
was that that not only him arriving but
then what happens once he does arrive
based on what I've also one of our
childhood cinematic inspirations there's
a sequence at the end of Excalibur where
Lancelot shows up in the battle and I
was remember how rousing that was when I
would watch it as a kid you know your
heroes on the edge of the feet and in
one of them you know having gone through
like great pain shows up to save him it
just it felt like the right moment the
only devious thing for us those it was
it was a fake out I mean it was all
story driven it was who was where and
which character dynamics we wanted to
exploit I think even at one point we had
Thor going to Titan instead of Wakanda
and made the decision that we wanted the
climax to happen on earth and not on
Titan so we moved through the earth and
we don't simply think about like oh well
what do we want the teams to be at the
end of the movie a lot of us figuring
that out is how do we get there you know
those small little choices we make along
the way that end up pushing somebody one
place or the other
ends up dictating where they we knew we
wanted Peter with Tony we knew that we
wanted strange and Tony together because
we wanted to see that two egotistical
characters going at each other we knew
cap was in hiding on earth so that was
always gonna stay that way and a pairing
cap with the Chavo is gonna be a really
you know after that final scene in Civil
War to see those two characters reunite
we need that would be a powerful moment
and you know where would you run 200 to
be the most protected clearly what kinda
so well everything sort of logically
starts to answer itself as you move
through the story
I mean our DJ was probably the only one
to actually read the entire script
I think Benedict got the script that was
included his scenes only I mean evidence
might have read part of our motivation
to do that is it just takes a lot of
pressure off of people cuz it is hard to
constantly censor yourself about what
you're saying how you talk cuz these
movies are your whole life you know it's
everything you're doing all day long
like the inclination is to talk about it
so we take a lot of pressure off of
people by just saying okay yeah the less
you know the less you have to mind
yourself Hemsworth's character you know
Thor doesn't need to know what Captain
America is doing for most of infinity
war so Hemsworth reads his scenes and
Evans riittää scenes and then if they
don't read the rest of the movie they
don't know what's going on with it that
makes it easier for them they have
conversations with people kept it going
through even more so and again it's more
secrets in an game of Aaron infinity or
it is a more tedious way to work to be
honest with you because we do have to do
more discussion on set about context
because they don't have the the entirety
of the script to rely on so you do have
to work harder to work in this way but
it we believe it's worth it because the
payoff is that special experience in the
movie theater for all the audience's we
grew up watching movies there's a lot
less context here to read things in the
newspaper maybe you saw something on
television you know the only way you
knew movie was out was you flip to the
movie page and there was a big
advertisement for it
and we loved that I mean it really
profoundly affected us when we saw
movies me it's so little context for the
movies we're emotionally driven to make
sure that people get the same experience
today in a culture where everyone wants
to know things yesterday
maybe maybe it's all yeah maybe there's
not a real frame and that whole training
I don't know that's interesting we
really haven't focused that much on
what's coming next we were focused so
hard on delivering this movie and we
haven't had a lot of conversations with
Kevin about where he's going so we might
be the wrong people to ask that question
yeah I think it was it's very creatively
liberating to Joe and I and almost like
a creative discipline for us to not
specifically not think about the future
like we really wanted to be focused on
just telling the end of the story and
that's it